un art il fait un temps de merde mais
j'en pouvais plus rester chez moi
bonjour messieurs bonjour les hits moi
je ne vois pas de live pour votre chien
mais quoi je ne vois pas non plus de
sacs de courses
non non merde là les grosses balance
tâchant de nous en aller et de faire
profil bas
discrètement vous avez votre attestation
mère de mon attestation mais oui bien
sûr bien sûr j'ai une attestation
attendez que je vous la trouvez elle est
dans ma capuche et dans ma poche elle
est dans mon sac et dans ma voiture dans
les bons jours que j'ai une attestation
une attestation vous avez vous voyez le
temps qui fait je veux dire je suis pas
sortie pour le plaisir je suis pas
sortie pour le plaisir sous un temps
pareil regardez moi je suis tout trempé
là j'ai pas d'attestation merdes le dire
que j'ai pas d'attestation bon ok j'ai
pas la tentation mais regardez je vais
enfin je vous en fais rien et regarde et
je prends un stylo et je vous écris une
attestation voilà vous la voyez
l'attestation attestation l'attestation
tu la vois l'attestation l'attestation à
regarder la télé à sion et à bâle et va
chercher
ah bah merde même pour faire ça vous
êtes trop con vous auriez fait un
excellent collabos en 40
messieurs j'attends toujours votre
attestation mais c'est pas vrai elle est
au nas temps attestations et reste assez